one problem left problem number 20.
there are 75
more women
than men enrolled in linden college
if n men enrolled than in terms of n
what percentage of those enrolled are
men
all right so
let's say
well they're saying that uh
n
is men so n
is equal to number of men
number
of men right they tell us that and there
are 75 more women than men right so what
is equal to the number of women
number of women we know that there are
75 more women than men so it must be n
plus 75
and then i think i'm coming down with
something and then they say well in
terms of n what percentage of those
enrolled are men
so
it's the number of men
over
so if we want to know the fraction that
are men it's the number of men over the
total number of students so the total
number of students is going to be the
men plus the women
so the men
is n
plus the women is n plus 75
right so this tells us the fraction that
are men so this is
n
over 2 n
plus 75
and then if i want you know this would
be some decimal number and then if i
want to convert this to a percentage i'd
multiply it times 100
times
100.
and add a percent sign right here and if
i wanted to rewrite that would be 100
n
over 2n plus 75
and that is
choice e
i have all this extra time i don't know
what to do with i guess i will let you
use it more productively than watching
me do nothing on a video i'll see you in
the next uh sat section